[Applause]
oh my gosh that was so good
[Applause]
as soon as the judges would do something
like that i didn't expect i was like
okay keep it together just keep singing
almost on the song keep it together you
can fan girl later
that's been gone but used
it's a very loaded song but um for me
personally it means like you know
having to
grow up and having to become a different
person my sisters also love this song
and waitress was the first musical we've
seen altogether i felt your whole
life story in that film
oh sorry about that one
i did a cover of she used to be mine
back in december of 2020 and that was
the video that like pushed my account
over the edge
and like started like the followers
flowing in and again i have such like
such a connection to that song
[Music]
what has been the wildest reaction that
you've gotten outside of that audition
room
to your audition that day
um
probably sara bareilles posting it on
her instagram story that was insane
what were the songs that almost made it
but didn't make it
so some of the songs were um she-wolf by
sia which isn't like a crazy popular
song but it's a song that
is originally like a dance song like an
edm track
and i turned it into a ballad which was
super super i love that arrangement just
because it brings such a different level
to the emotion
[Music]
some other people that have really
inspired me would be like adele is
probably the biggest one just because i
grew up with
kind of singing her music first and
being like i love this music it makes
people feel things and that was kind of
what i wanted to do with my voice moving
forward in my
[Music]
career see canadians are loving that
you're toronto representing
you know for canada yeah what was what's
the audition process like the audition
process was for me it was super
nerve-wracking just because i was from
canada and i was like what's gonna
happen like i know it's an american tv
show right so anything could happen at
the point of audition and i really just
tried to keep like my head on my
shoulders while going through the
audition process just because it was it
was a lot but i wouldn't change it for
the world
you